that cause it because i know right bruh
yeah like he's an rb singer
i don't know ladies running like brian
all right this is how rappers when they
about to premiere this track and they
get
oh you're are you nervous about your
diss track i'm not nervous now it's your
birthday guess we're like yeah
let's do we're letting you hear this
stuff on the i'm firing the kids yeah
yeah i feel good about it you feel good
about it i've been great i'm feeling
cake yeah feeling great can you give
them the origin story before we premiere
tell them how it started how it started
sure so
you were dating a girl yeah big sean
[ __ ] your girl
don't say it like that now man hey if
you want me to do it
i'm gonna do it right do it i'm gonna do
it wrong right you're right i'll do it
wrong okay
i'm doing it wrong go ahead do it so
you're dating this little philly bird
and she slended she slid into big sean's
dna
she was that she was just taking down
your degree no a restaurant she was that
he was
she was a host at the restaurant and he
uh oh even better she was a host at the
restaurant and he
he put game on her well i was picking
her up oh
no and before she got in your car she
gave him her digits yeah
and then wait and then what restaurant
was it can we say that
um tell me and then we'll bleep it out
yeah okay
so so what we'll edit out the name of
the restaurant but fans to figure out
so big sean went to go reach for that
[ __ ]
fortune cookie and was like what's up
girl what's up girl here's the thing
she was very unprofessional because uh
he slid her a tip
and uh his number oh
and yeah why are you okay okay so wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait all right
yeah keep going
i'm about to pick her up and she he know
he see me
i was like bro it's my girl you know i
say that but i don't think that happened
i gave him my look i gave him that look
like hold on i bet i bet he saw
you saw you and your was a honda
nissan nissan nose
so i bet he he was getting picked up in
like his he had a base
he had a bands right probably a s-class
and looked at you it was like a black
one black
so so how long after that did she come
over and get that big dick
so later on like during that week she
said she was going out with the girls
and i figured i was like i bet she said
she'll be home around like one
something like that right so it gets one
i call her a caller
it's going straight to voicemail she
butt dialed me back oh
and what'd you hear i heard i heard him
do you want to have another drink
and uh it's like it was intimate and i
heard like and then did you hear the
background i don't
know wait that's a big sean line in one
of his songs
what uh he the line was something along
the lines of like
him but dialing his girl and she hears
girls screaming the whole night
like he's out at a party with other
chicks
and then uh he butt dials his girlfriend
his girlfriend hears everything that
he's doing that [ __ ] wrote a
song
about my life
before he even knew him you know just to
oh so why are you mad at him yeah you
should be mad at the girl
yeah why are you better why why
no this is not for me this is for every
average guy in america
oh that's right that's right you know
everyone has averaged joe
so i had a show it's not even just
you're you're the owner of average joe's
jim
average joe's jail yes but how does she
know how here's the thing she's willing
to let me tell you let me tell you
so i couldn't tell i couldn't like let
her know that i knew
she was with him instead of our girls so
what i did was
i just kept playing her his music around
my girl the whole time
to see her like yeah to like see see the
reaction and i and as of me playing
songs you think you're trying to mind
[ __ ] her but you know what she's
thinking about when you're playing music
she's singing
[Laughter]
she said she didn't she said it was he
had a condom now now here's the thing
um two things you should know about this
when i was playing his music i realized
trying to catch her in her lies i
realized his music wasn't all that
so that's why i'm giving the diss track
today is because i got to prove to him
like this is where rapping really is
oh yeah so go ahead are you are you
what's that talk to me are you are you
expecting a response i'm not expecting
anything
like the response is already there he
see me i see him now now do you think
you're going to get uh pure fire from
this from your ass for doing it
what are you hoping uh no i'm not come
on i'm happy in a happy relationship
yeah i know that but do you think that
she texts me today how happy is the
relationship that you got to make a diss
track about a dude that guy
again that's what i'm trying to figure
out why move her
dog you gotta start living
right yeah i wasn't i was on the new
thing i wasn't going to press it until i
feel like he was antagonizing me
oh with that outfit that outfit that's
when he's i know you were thinking about
it before he did that oh he didn't i was
i listened
to him yeah i bet you've been you've
been sitting on this for a long time
does it bother you that we like we know
he's back in hate you know what i'm
saying like we know his
nickname big sean came from from his
size
but from gold dick well here's it's well
documented it's not well documented
because yeah ariana moved on so fast
that
you know let's just be honest i mean
dude she's with a real estate agent yeah
come on now yeah that's gonna let you
know that big shine is poor little shiny
no
shout out to shout out i want this well
document i'm a big tron fan
i got it i like being sean yeah me too
also after she did
sean she did pete davidson who who she
claimed the term big dick energy after
correct so she went from one big dick to
another big one hold on she never said
big dick with a
big sean though she never mentioned it
we know his picture got leaked yeah no
we know i like mine too i photoshopped
it
oh this is funny you you don't want to
go
bro you're saying
well here's the thing now i'm not saying
you got a small one but it ain't a big
one like shawn's
listen we can call some of my past we
can call six figure
i'm i'm pretty prove it i got a thread
i got a third leg third leg why don't
you tighten this [ __ ] and start only
yeah
that's what you should be doing you're
not making money off this diss track
do the diss track and be like what's up
man and then uh
you go to my onlyfans.com you'll see
what you're missing girl i can
i can't do that xbox shout out to xbox
uh
will you i'm the you know again super
bowl commercial i can't show you
well maybe once that campaign's over we
can do it yeah
yeah well we'll get chan to be there
mess with the lighting and stuff for you
yeah angles i'm trying not to i'm trying
not to crack but brendan
what he's saying he don't have to be
there for the picture just set him up no
i step light and then he'll exit and
snap boom he'll come in yeah we blasted
out well
how here's another thing another thing
right
how what if this diss track gets a lot
of like buzz
and i become a rapper what if ooh that'd
be sick and then you're like touring but
then you got the pressure of like
your cardi b now what do you mean like
she wasn't ready to be a rap star so she
had a bunch of people writing her music
and [ __ ] she's like i guess i want to do
this so who wrote yours
again that's a great question again a
little browse wait a little bit browse
i told you i told you i played this diss
track right can we
i'm going to see you here no no no no no
okay okay little brown just know just
know it's all me all right i played him
his birthday you had some inspiration
i had some inspiration listen i asked a
little brows like bro
i'm over my head right can you can you
give me something he sent back a whole
track and
you could just tell it was too much
rapper [ __ ] i was yeah you know what
i'm trying it was too deep i was like
well jelly roll was busy now now i i had
to see a big shot from the side
why would you say yes you look similar
no no one again
it's the the haircut and the like the
way you just shoot you guys are both
good looking dude yeah well he looks
like your little brother he yeah
he's he's my prototype you can say
something like that protege
it's all good dude yeah it's all good i
like that
protege well should we just play the
track and then go from there all right
let's just play it it is your birthday
guys ready you ready
29 years old no can we act like this as
a talent show and uh
yeah cat me and jebel just like american
idol right
all right you're the
uh randy randy come on dog yeah come on
that's a note for me dawg
and i'll be simon cowell okay okay okay
is uh
before we play it can i thank a lot of
people i want to thank y'all
for like his family like just like they
don't get to do that american idol
man because listen i told you i'm not on
board for this i'm a big sean fan
yeah again i don't know if i support it
but but if it's good i'm gonna give you
your money
i will drop you drop it i'm dropping
drop it i might wrap it up find it find
it
mike right here oh yeah but i mean you
know you're gonna wrap it i'm gonna no
no we're gonna play this
oh thank you here we go no i'm just
saying we want it
professionally done
what the hell are you doing oh that's
justin
all right
[ __ ] you don't even make good
music
[Music]
when she was with you sean
it was busy
[Music]
what the hell is going on what you mean
i mean you just going back and forth
about this big shot
just because they don't even know you
man what's what's up this is fire right
it was fine he took my girl
anyway man can we get back to the song
man let's go and do all that yeah you're
right
y'all didn't believe it
[Music]
holy [ __ ] now it got uh
it got a little detailed when you're
like you're working at pf changs
and y'all were in there and you were the
lettuce wraps and even the manchester i
know right
he's sweet when i was out i was outside
my nissan
sentra for an hour waiting you know
and one thing one thing about rolly boy
you got to get it off your chest
yeah that's called get it off you feel
better now is that what you feel better
now i feel great i feel uh
i got it like it's in the butt now like
you got that out of the way
yeah no i can go back to being malik b
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i want to shout out everyone that's
like with me for the ride all the fans
little sean you can go back to making
weak music and it's a matter of fact
i really like big sean i'm just going to
say that out loud oh no i'm a fan
oh you're just doing oh you're just yeah
let's go let's go salmon simon is all is
at the end
yeah let's go to ryan seacrest go ahead
uh secretary johnson
secrets doesn't judge but since i do
have a musical background i'm not going
to lie i unexpected
yeah he does he's the only one with the
me well chappelle knows me
but you know what i'm me and cat are the
only ones without a musical background
now i have some hidden pipes on me but
i'm not
getting pipes
professional music background as well
yeah professional yes professional paid
for my duties
uh i expected something to be way lamer
yeah the fact yeah the fact that it was
actually like funny and and like
the lyrics are great the stop you know
he stopped it pause it
went back in i got to give you like a
solid eight thank you i appreciate it
and that's out of ten
it's out of a 20 eight yeah 10.
eight or ten okay that's a solid score
that's just from a from a guy
and us and by the way i went all out
with these this i i was paid for my
money
dude i paid a lot of money for this when
i heard it i'm like i expected i i
envisioned how much time and energy you
put into it yeah that's what makes
this video i wrote it where was it
silver lake
all right i also was very surprised
it sounds so much better than i thought
it would and you're
really good i think you're better than a
lot of soundcloud rappers i've heard
i think you should go and take this
track put it on soundcloud and start
making like
comedic like fake disses to other people
like start off with justin timberlake
next see how that goes
well that's good advice that's great
almost like yeah
yeah type of like because you're not bad
that's the thing you have good flow
execution was great thank you thank you
well i try to i try to embody the
cadence of like a drake or
or
that's a great reference yeah damn can i
take this judging very soon
very good i'm surprised nope okay uh
i thought it was [ __ ] hilarious i
thought it was actually really funny
the flow was really good especially when
you like spread it was like man yeah
that was actually pretty dope
but it is it like it's comedically it
did crack me the [ __ ] up
you know what i mean so yeah i do get
like a lonely island riff raff
like uh little dicky like type vibes
where it just
can be it's just funny it's just funny
it's very you know
well but like but like as far as like
you know musically
yeah execution yeah the execution was
great what would you grade me
uh what would i get she didn't even give
you a grade yeah it was oh i'd give you
eight
okay two weeks yeah two eight honestly
i i'll give you eight point five oh i
think you're gonna say ten
i thought i'd go ten i'd have to bring
it back down
[Laughter]
we're all wrong before the birthday
uh yeah i was super surprised i thought
it was gonna be a complete [ __ ] show
um but it was really well done is
professional and i thought it was
it was funny my favorite part was the
details of the pf changs
yeah yeah and then the eating sweet and
sour and then
also a cameo by justin whose voice is
hilarious yeah he's so
so funny you should get into like
animation like cartoons or something
seriously you don't at the top of the uh
part of like when he's we're doing the
introduction and you hear that
he's that's his real laugh yeah he's so
funny can i tell you a funny story in
the studio
he shocked all of us like me and the
producer and uh my homeboy
and he was like justin do that laugh
again and he smokes justin smokes he was
like all right
do it just like that he goes
what we stopped he was like no just to
do it before he was like man i'm trying
i'm trying man
it's so stupid yeah i thought it was
good though i thought that was really
good yeah when you give them it
way better like i said i thought it was
going to be so
trash i was like brothers i think eight
i think eight is fair yes right for
first time i ever do recording
right that's why i gave you now listen i
don't know if i put all my energy in
becoming a soundcloud rapper i will
i'm not but i don't know if that's your
future hold on we don't know i mean xbox
they they
you know does that what did they do with
xbox well i told them i might be you
know they only said they called so you
think if xbox was picking you and big
sean out of a lineup
who do you think they're going to pick
well i already got like rapport with
them
well you know what we should do i mean
because kanye found big sean you know
his story
yeah he's a radio dj guy found him so
maybe we could have kanye maybe
freestyle for kanye
passes you take good music i mean here's
the thing you [ __ ] on good music
but if connie called you up right now i
was like yo man you heard the diss track
we'll sign you right now
your dick would be so hard yeah and i
had to take a pill
now now i would i will freestyle i gotta
freestyle right now if kanye called me
like say you kanye
all right i'm kanye on the spot all
right i need to be or
you don't need to be you pick up phone
and he like
hey malik how long was this i love it
it's gay yeah it's easy easy it's easy
i'm wearing your shoes right now
everybody wears them hey listen
[Laughter]
i heard the diss track yeah the little
sound district yeah okay yeah that's me
this was my boy
yeah but we're looking for new talent on
good music oh yeah
i'm glad is he still on please yeah no
he's actually killing it uh
what do you got though okay you want me
to go right now yeah just give me
something cause i'm i gotta
i got [ __ ] to do okay okay i said joe
i said people want to have fun
like brendan when he had a man bun cat
she with stevie blue eyes but checking
out the melodies like
get the vocal out of his eyes don't
squint just bit
chappelle you know me he had anger
management issues
thank you for your time
that's a sign that you leave this where
it is okay and i respect that yeah how
about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song